[Music]
there was this video circling around the
internets and it caused the discussion
so which is nowhere the British boy went
to Thailand and had sex with a [ __ ]
and then he kept trying to see her
wiener or I could just tell you this is
a tweet that was said by this woman
named Wendy she said after much much
consideration and exhausting every
opportunity for hashtag American
Airlines to do the right thing I've
decided to share my assaults from the
passenger behind me
oh no further threats from an American
airline flight attendant she offered him
a complimentary cocktail here's the
video that she hosted you know American
Airlines dirt see Scott smaller oh yeah
well hop is such a bill what's happening
here is that woman reclined her seat
yeah
this man is punching the back of would
have [ __ ] constantly like a
two-year-old and as you can see this man
he's in the back row so he can't recline
so it turns out that earlier before she
started reporting this he had asked her
to move her seat up so he can eat this
guy's immature as a [ __ ]
oh yeah and so he she did she moved her
seat up as he ate and then once the food
was put away she reclined it again and
and then he started punching the seat
according to her that he was punching it
so badly that like you could even call
that gets annoying though like the
punching or the reclining a little bit
like so there was a really big guy
behind me when I was flying back from
Europe and I don't blame the dude but
the tapping on the chair okay turn
around and [ __ ] his ass up but like it
wasn't on purpose though how was it
tapping it he was fat so his knee weight
is like touching the the thing and then
the table like it literally hit his
stomach so if he moves like this it's
constantly moving her chair yeah and he
was like he had a book and he was
writing notes so just that shaking ah
poor dude making the chair go like that
in my chair wasn't even reclined back so
just that movement alone just sit in my
egg zero it just felt like this the
whole time tap tap oh [ __ ] I was like I
literally where hmm [ __ ] and then I
turned around and I was like oh [ __ ] I
feel bad dude like he can't control it
yeah well this guy could and so but
that's a dick [ __ ] [ __ ] ass did you
really punch the channel she's saying
that before she started recording he was
actually punching it okay her chair so
we don't know if that's true cuz we
don't have proof of that but once she
started filming he could he was looking
at the camera so he'd kind of like she
says he like hum down a bit yeah thing
but he was still like at it and then so
she called over the flight attendant and
then the flight
attendant was being rude to her why I
don't know that's what she's saying so
she said when the flight attendant came
she rolled her eyes at me and said what
she then told him it was tight back
there oh really and gave him some rum
so alcoholic beverage she told me I had
to delete the video it's against a law
to video on a plane I asked her name and
she gave me a passenger disturbance
notice this is all coming from from her
right cuz we don't know what really went
down
yeah really don't so but this this
started a whole discussion where people
on one side said well you [ __ ] up why
are you reclining your seat that's you
know he can't he barely has any rudder
we have a [ __ ] you're an idiot and then
the other and then the other people said
what the [ __ ] she paid for that seat she
has a right to recline wherever the [ __ ]
she wants that she she purchased that
see she did you whatever snipers I
blamed the airline because I feel like
every year it's getting more and more
crass to the point where I remember
getting in and I'm like oh I can't even
there's like an inch from my knee to the
[ __ ] next chair what the [ __ ] I don't
think you girl no no but for sure though
American Airlines because a glimmer in
his eye maybe American Airlines is not
my favorite la hate it I flew back
American yesterday from Miami and I paid
for the the Wi-Fi for the entire trip
was like $18 and it's a five and a half
hour flight something like that the [ __ ]
went out like the last one ever so I'm
sending emails and everything and then
it just like everything just stopped and
like there's nobody you can contact like
they didn't reset it or anything like
that it's like oh I just wasted money
but you know who gives it to you for
free JetBlue America now it's like hey
my internet went out that I paid for and
they're like move it seat back two
inches we're gonna cut you up out don't
complain we'll crunches oh hey I'm not a
smaller I think it's yeah it's not
ranked high at all an American will
cancel a flight like an hour before the
flight it no no reason for it and they
won't help you rebook you have the light
just actively go tall in the plaza when
you're accepting stuff all those is
it's they can it says they can cancel
anytime with any explanation yeah you
know what they do it out to which
[ __ ] sucks so back in the day like if
you just have a flight and you go to
your terminal you can just sit there and
like take a nap if you there like an
hour too early now they'll switch gates
like everything they don't have this
[ __ ] figured out so there'll be times
where I sit there I'm okay cool I'm at
like terminal 30 I'll take a nap or
something I look oh you're getting
switch to terminal 17 I'm like what the
[ __ ] you get to 17 and outside 28 so
you're just walking up and down like
everywhere until they figure out where
the [ __ ] you're your plane's it's a good
life hack is just stay where the flight
attendants and all that because they
kick it there too and if I see that move
I'm like I'm going with you I do say
that that needs to be a class for
etiquette in the air yeah because people
just do the most read a like I know
there were a lot of people here and we
champion point who is but I know you're
farting yeah that was about to stay that
oh I hate it I got the arrows fall good
I know you're smarter no [ __ ] smell
you boy we smell you not only that you
suck when you're getting up from your
chair in the air this is what you do
lift yourself up right you've been
through the ow yeah lean on your seat
don't [ __ ] yeah I see bag handles
right here they're [ __ ] armrests for
you to push up yeah and then you lean
against the seats that you're crossing
over don't pull my [ __ ] seat back I'm
watching what are you doing
don't be a dick like Jenna just be a
good wing fellows here now see and you
see this little lady sure gonna put her
[ __ ] bag up why are you I see bet on
already
you wouldn't we're not even taxing you
have this [ __ ] lady out different
lady you're bagging I can't get that
getting it up there while your mind up
that
so we're up there yeah that's one thing
I don't like about a lot of people that
travel they don't have this community
mindset so for me it's like I reach I'm
speaking for them know like okay I'm MIT
I'm cool but then if you want to help
the old lady she can get to her seat so
the other twenty people behind can all
get to their seat let's think together
and move together but lock people I'm
here I'm ready to go haha have you seen
that video that viral video where it's
the plane landed no one takes their
seatbelts off everyone stands up when
it's their turn to stand up and exit and
then they're like this this is a
Canadian flight that's my [ __ ] we land
immediately everyone takes out their
seat belts and stands up and they stand
there for [ __ ] 45 minutes what right
for what
first of all you take your seatbelt off
when the playing first lands like it's
still going 500 miles an hour where the
[ __ ] are you going do you hear that yeah
what are you doing
and don't be clapping when we land
safely that's the [ __ ] we supposed to do
why are you clapping at the [ __ ]
pilot doing his job you clap when your
barber does jeez no [ __ ] amazing land
stop with the stupid dramatics and all
that theatrics I don't laugh usually
happens when there's turbulence all day
yeah but and you finally land and
they're like we [ __ ] survived but you
know what that's traffic every day in LA
you know get to your destination like we
made it sometimes I do what do you you
should stop drinking a job no it's not
me dude sir I was an ambulance hit me
last night ambulance yeah came out of
[ __ ] nowhere yeah let me say Sam it
would've been almost for me that
ambulance would have hit me I would have
slowed and then the owner of a new
ambulance and a hospital the other thing
people don't fight that sucks is they do
that [ __ ] where they're walking down the
aisles and then for some reason like
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah if you also if you
wearing a big backpack take your [ __ ]
backpack off and hold it in the front so
it's not weapon people and a [ __ ]
head as you try to do
your [ __ ] bag on there and oh excuse
me I'm sorry I can't see behind me well
yeah take the [ __ ] backpack off
[ __ ] yeah I'm glad it has a
clamshell - that was like 30 pounds of
[ __ ] precedent thank you thank you
for that [ __ ] hisat with the portable
speaker thank you so much I feel like
the flight attendants they purposely
knock your [ __ ] ass while they hit
the Wat when they weren't going down the
aisle with their car they go yeah you
gave the problems they don't definitely
get they're gonna get that gig back on
you for so fun I can't wait to travel in
defense of all the farters on the plane
no no [ __ ] times before you get on
your flag bro okay walk to the bathroom
and fart in the [ __ ] instead it's not
that it doesn't even smell either
because you're literally injecting your
wife why you fart on your way I don't
find I think the family of those farters
those fighters maybe they should make
some snacks that don't cause so much gas
don't eat snacks don't eat snacks you
guys hear that farters what about your
[ __ ] defense you nasty bastard no
snacks are the ones that are causing the
gas yeah I see the guys in Delta I see
the guy next to me get the cheese plate
in am i forget cheese and fiber so I
don't ever and I can always pass gas
I've never fought on plans I would never
do that to somebody unwillingly no you
just call it about the fart just open it
[Music]
everyone knows it was you Bart I'm
talking about the guy next to me okay
I'm next to you what we don't have all
the time then or maybe you go just like
it is and then you open up and you kick
out your leg up take out the magazine
and you just start going like this this
is why he isn't on a plane nothing can
go wrong
you bring matches on the planes
gathering a lighter this is like there's
light blue light on your tray table no
he needs to walk to the [ __ ] path the
crazy thing is I didn't know that they
just recycled the air in the [ __ ]
airplane man yeah
new air I just recently like learned
that that's crazy now you breathing
breath yeah breathing breath and fart
afford me the body body this should new
thing but it's clean air it's clean air
they filter it
it's what clean what's there I know what
I don't believe if I heard about the
whole coffee thing I definitely don't
believe that I watch Bill Gates drink
his own piss and [ __ ] and then he's like
this is delicious so I'm sure it's clean
man well he has all the money in the
world to wash it out and [ __ ] heal
himself so I think that's different
wait I didn't hear from you guys though
which side are you on the one where she
[ __ ] up or he [ __ ] up well I don't
know enough to the airline [ __ ] up it
sounds like he [ __ ] up but I don't
have all the info yeah just doing this
to the [ __ ] that already involved it
yeah that's not the way to deal with it
and then I'll be honest with you I feel
like he would he would never do that to
him no yeah he's definitely just trying
to like like just go as masculine around
if he [ __ ] did that to me Oh
trust him believable I won't tell on him
I'm definitely nothing to fight in air
and be put on a no-fly list but I will
definitely press charges and show up to
court to point you out well for her
though she's really frustrated because
the airline hasn't done anything about
it and she's like what the [ __ ] but it's
American Airlines like hey we're
American Airlines what the [ __ ] you
expect be like they're like they'll
cancel flight you never know what you
gonna do no walk yeah no you know rebook
so cute oh I asked over the customer so
if that just makes me wanna be
super-rich yeah me too yeah
[Music]
[Music]